EVA KOR: Thank you very much
for those of you who have come.
Thank you, Emily,
May, [INAUDIBLE],
and May's boyfriend--
what's his name?
AUDIENCE: Nam.
EVA KOR: Nam.
OK.
All of you who helped
organize this event,
I am very pleased to be here.
I can tell you, before
I begin my presentation,
that I probably use Google
a minimum of 10 to 20 times
a day.
Whatever I don't
know, I go to Google.
If I don't know how to spell
it, I start spelling it,
Google is going to
spell it for me right.
But I have to be close to a
computer, because my iPhone
I use for writing and sending
messages-- emails, or tweets,
or whatever-- but Google helps
me with all the information.
I usually like to
start my presentation
with the following statement.
My name is Eva Kor.
I am a survivor of Auschwitz, a
survivor of medical experiments
conducted by Doctor Mengele,
and now that I am 81 years old,
I am trying to survive old age.
And I am finding it a bigger
challenge than I realized.
I was born in a tiny village in
1934 in Transylvania, Romania.
Being born in the 1930s
or '40s a Jewish child,
my destiny was decided
already, because Hitler already
was in power in 1933.
Our village had 100
families, all Christian,
except the Mozes
family was Jewish.
And from the time that I
was six years old, when
the war started, and the village
was occupied by the Hungarians,
persecution against
Jews began immediately.
And I learned that children can
be very mean to one another,
particularly if they are taught
to do so, and rewarded for it.
By first grade when we entered,
we were called dirty Jews,
and the kids beat my
twin sister, Miriam, up.
And when we complained
to the teacher,
the teachers punished us.
So we learned within the
first few days in school
that there was no help for us.
When we went home, I expected
my mother to march to school
and straighten it all out.
But even though she was
a wonderful human being--
she hugged us, kissed
us, and cried with us--
but said, children,
I am very sorry.
There is nothing I can do.
You have to learn
that we are Jews,
and you have to
learn to take it.
My father's attitude was
a little bit different.
He told us since we
were going to school,
to be the best students in
that one room schoolhouse,
and we were.
When we got home,
he said we needed
to help with the work
around the big pig farm.
And at night, he said
you say your prayers.
And he was very
strict about that,
because we were Orthodox Jews.
And he said God is going to help
us, and everything will be OK,
and do not worry.
And, of course, I believed
it, but as time went on,
things changed.
Every six months or
so, new rules, new laws
were passed against us.
And in 1942, when I
was eight years old,
is that new laws that year
were that Jews could not
hire anybody but Jewish people.
And in our Christian village,
that was not possible.
My mother got sick.
We tried to help--
the four girls--
but we couldn't handle all the
work on an old fashioned farm.
My father asked for a permit
to travel to the big city
to try to hire a Jewish
lady, but that was denied.
So here I was eight years old,
and our life was very, very
difficult. And so
I told my father,
daddy, I think time
has come that we
should escape to Romania.
The Romanian border was just
one hour by foot from our house,
and the rumor was that
life for Jews in Romania
was much better.
And it turned out
it was correct.
Romania refused to let
Germany pick up the Jews.
They said, oh, we will take care
of them in our ghettos here,
but you cannot take them away.
So all of the Jews
of Romania survived.
But my father said
to me, you are just
a little girl, eight years old.
What on earth do you understand
about the big issues in life?
I have a theory that children
between the ages of six and 13,
or 12, are a lot smarter than
parents give them credit.
After 13, the
hormones set in, and I
don't know what happens to
all of these smart, wonderful
children.
But I can explain it to you why.
Children between six and
12 function by instinct.
They do not
rationalize everything
that's going around-- do not
try to figure it out rationally.
And I could sense it in
every ounce of my being
that things were
getting very bad.
But my father said to me,
you are just a little girl.
You don't understand it.
We have a nice home.
We have plenty of food.
You children go to school.
And then he
rationalized, I think,
and the Nazis won't come.
The Germans won't come
to this tiny village
to pick up six Jews.
Well, daddy, I am eternally
sorry that you were 100% wrong,
and I, as a eight-year-old
kid, was 100% right.
I sure wish it was
the other way around.
So in March of 1944, we were
taken to a regional ghetto.
Two and a half months
later-- last week of May--
we were herded into cattle cars,
traveling for about four days
without food, without water.
It was very hot in
those cattle cars.
And we arrived in Auschwitz.
Of course, we didn't know
where we were being taken.
The cattle car doors opened.
Thousands of people poured out
onto a little strip of land
called the selection platform.
In my opinion, there
is no other strip
of land like the selection
platform-- measuring
85 feet long by 35
feet wide-- that
witnessed as many millions
of people being ripped apart
from their families forever.
So as we were standing there,
my mother grabbed my twin sister
and me by the hand.
We were her youngest
children, and she
hoped that as long as she could
hold onto us, that somehow
she could protect us.
Everything was moving very fast.
And I-- my childish
curiosity-- I looked around,
trying to figure
out what on earth
is this place, when I realized
that my father and two older
sisters disappeared
in the crowd.
Never ever did I see them again.
As we were holding onto
Mother for dear life,
a Nazi was running, yelling
in German, twins, twins.
We did not volunteer
any information.
He noticed us.
Miriam and I looked alike,
and we were dressed alike,
and he demanded to know from
my mother if we were twins.
And my mother didn't
know what to say.
She asked, is that good?
And the Nazi nodded yes,
and my mother said yes.
At that moment, we were
pulled in one direction,
my mother was pulled in
the opposite direction.
We were crying, she was crying.
And that was the
last time I saw her.
I didn't even understand
that that would happen,
because I might have done
something to run back
to my mother and say goodbye.
We became part of a group
of little girls, all twins.
In our group, there were
13 sets of little girls
between the ages of two and 16.
And one mother, who had
seven-year-old twins-- and she
was my mother's friend.
Her name was Mrs. [? Jangary ?].
We were taken to a big
building for processing,
which took the whole
day-- basically,
sitting naked, and not knowing
what would happen to us.
Finally the processing began.
We were given short haircuts.
Our dresses were returned with
a huge red cross on the back,
and we were tattooed
by heating a needle
over the flame of a lamp.
And when the needle got hot,
they dipped it into ink,
and they burned
into my left arm,
dot by dot, the
capital letter A-7063.
Miriam became capital A-7064.
Auschwitz was the only Nazi
camp that tattooed its inmates.
My husband is a survivor of
four years in Buchenwald.
He does not have a tattoo.
Once we were processed, we
were taken to our barrack.
Crude and filthy
modular horse barns.
There were no windows.
We were given bunk beds on
the bottom that were covered
with a thin straw mattress.
And we finally thought, after
four days in the cattle car,
that we could stretch
out and maybe sleep.
But human beings cannot function
after such a traumatic day.
So I kept tossing and
turning, and as I did,
I noticed something big and
dark moving on the floor.
And I counted them, and when I
got to five, I said to myself,
these are the biggest mice
I have ever seen, and began
screaming, "Mice."
A girl from the top bunk said,
silly kid, these are not mice,
they are rats.
You better get used to them,
because they are everywhere.
And they were.
So now I couldn't even
try to go back to sleep.
I went to the latrine.
And as I entered
the place, there
on the filthy latrine floor
were the scattered corpses
of three children.
I have never ever seen
anybody dead before.
But the message to me was
clear that in this place,
children were dying.
So right then and there
I made a silent pledge,
that I will do anything and
everything within my power
to make sure that Miriam
and I shall not end up
on that filthy latrine floor.
That we will somehow survive,
and walk out of this camp
alive.
And I even had an
image in my mind
of how Miriam and I might
look when we walked out
of this camp alive.
Our daily routine-- we would
be awakened every morning
at 5:00 AM.
By 6:00 AM we were
outside for roll call.
And I can tell you
that by the time
it was winter of 1944,
'45, [INAUDIBLE],
my dress was filled with
holes, and so were my shoes.
We did not get any
winter clothes.
I have no idea how
we survived it.
Just for the sake of getting
through my lecture faster,
I will just give you a
description of our experience
in the barrack.
We were mostly little girls.
At one time 200,
300, 400, depending
on how many [INAUDIBLE].
We were little girls between
the age of two and 16,
huddled in our filthy bunk beds,
crawling with lice and rats.
We were starved for food.
We were starved
for human kindness.
And we were starved for
the love of the mothers
and fathers we once had.
We had no rights, but we
had a fierce determination
to live one more day.
To survive one more experiment.
The experiments were
run six days a week,
and I was used in two
types of experiments.
Three days a week, we
would be placed naked
in a room for up to eight hours.
And they would measure just
about every part of my body,
and compare it to
my twin sister,
and compare it to charts.
These were not dangerous,
but even in Auschwitz I
had difficulty
coping with the fact
that I was reduced to the lowest
form of humanity in existence,
just a mass of breathing cells.
On alternate days-- on Tuesday,
Thursday, and Saturday--
we would be taken to another
lab that I call the blood lab.
There they would
tie both of my arms
to restrict the blood
flow, take a lot of blood
from my left arm, and give me
a minimum of five injections
into my right arm.
Those were the deadly ones.
The rumor was, in Auschwitz,
that these contained
drugs, diseases, and germs.
And that is probably a
pretty good assumption.
But we do not know
up to today what
was the content of
those injections,
nor what was the scope
of the experiments.
After one of those
injections I became very ill
with a very high fever, a fact
I desperately tried to hide.
My next visit to the
blood lab, instead
of tying my arms for blood
taking and injections,
they measured my fever, and
I knew I was in trouble.
I had a very high fever.
I was trembling
in the August sun.
My arms and legs were very
swollen, and very painful,
and I had huge red spots
throughout my body.
The hospital was
another barrack,
but filled with people who
looked more dead than alive.
Next morning, Mengele came
in with four other doctors.
He never ever examined me.
Just looked at my fever
chart, and then he
declared, laughing
sarcastically, saying,
too bad, she's so young, she
has only two weeks to live.
I knew he was right,
but I refused to die.
So I made a second
silent pledge that I
will prove Mengele wrong.
I will survive, and be
reunited with my twin sister.
For the following two weeks,
I have only one clear memory.
I remember crawling
on the barrack floor,
because I no longer could walk.
And I was crawling to reach the
other end of the barrack, where
there was one faucet with water,
because this barrack was not
even allocated water.
People were brought
there to die.
And as I was crawling,
I would fade in and out
of consciousness, and I
kept telling myself-- even
in a semiconscious state
of mind-- I must survive.
I must survive.
After two weeks, my fever
broke, and I immediately
felt a lot stronger
and a lot better.
It took me another three weeks
before my fever chart showed
normal, and, amazingly, I
was released and reunited
with my twin sister,
and the other twins.
But Miriam looked very sick,
and I could not understand that.
In Auschwitz, as I often
say, dying was very easy.
All around us was deaths.
Surviving was a full time job.
And the way that became
dangerous-- the dangerous sign
was-- if somebody would sit
and stare into space aimlessly,
that was a sign that
they have given up
their struggle,
because everybody
struggled to live one more day.
And that is the
way Miriam looked,
and I was very surprised.
And I said, what on
earth happened to you
in the five weeks that
I was in the hospital?
She said, I cannot
talk about it.
I will not talk about it.
And Miriam and I never talked
about Auschwitz until 1985.
The word Auschwitz never
came up in our conversation.
And my opinion is that children
who struggle for their life,
they cannot go back
to the experience,
because they have to feel
safe even as grownups.
And that feeling of
safety is very important,
and it's very
difficult to come by,
if their safety was
violated as children.
And second thing is that
most survivors of atrocities
are afraid if they talk about
it, they will fall apart.
My experience has been
that I have only remembered
as much as I could cope with.
So I said to Miriam, when
we talked about it in 1985,
I said, do you remember when
I was taken to the hospital?
She said, yes.
I said, what happened to you
while I was in the hospital?
Because there are no books
written about our experiments.
She said, well, for
the first two weeks,
I was kept in isolation, and
they were waiting for something
to happen.
I don't know what that was,
because they didn't tell me.
And I don't know if it
happened, or it didn't happen.
But it was the same two weeks
that Mengele said I would die.
I told Miriam, I
spoiled the experiment.
I survived.
Would I have died,
Miriam would have
been rushed to Mengele's
lab, killed with an injection
to the heart, and then
Mengele would have
done the comparative autopsies.
That information comes to me
from the Auschwitz Museum,
where they also
told me that Mengele
used 1,500 sets of twins-- 3,000
individuals in the experiments.
The estimated number of
survivors is 250 individuals.
Then I asked her
what happened to her
after the two weeks were up.
She said she was injected
with many injections that
made her feel very sick.
After the war, Miriam was always
weaker and sicker than I was.
She got married
in 1958 in Israel.
Expected her first
baby in 1960, and she
developed severe kidney
infections that did not
respond to any antibiotic.
Second pregnancy
in '63 got worse,
and this time the Israeli
doctors studied her,
and they found out that
Miriam's kidneys never
grew larger than the size
of a 10-year-old child.
I begged Miriam not to
have any more children.
And I said, you have two
children, that's pretty good.
But she had a third one, and
after her third child was born,
her kidneys were deteriorating.
And by 1987 she needed
to go on dialysis,
or have a kidney transplant.
Well, she didn't want
to live on dialysis.
I had a simple choice.
I had two kidneys, one sister.
Of course I donated
one of my kidneys,
and we were a perfect match.
At that hospital
near Tel Aviv, they
had been doing kidney
transplants for 10 years,
and they had 200
survivors-- 2,000 survivors.
And all of them were given
anti-rejection medication.
None of them developed
cancerous polyps like Miriam
did a year after the transplant.
And the doctors told
me that I should
try to find our files from
Auschwitz, because there
had to be something in
her body that was injected
in the camp that combined with
the anti-rejection medication
to create the cancer.
We never found our files.
Miriam's cancer metastasized,
and she died June 6, 1993.
I will take you
back to the camp,
because it's important
for me to describe
to you my state of mind as
a 10-year-old in Auschwitz.
I thought that the whole world
was one big concentration camp.
That everybody is
the world lived
like I lived, in
miserable conditions,
without famillies,
starving to death,
and guarded by
guards day and night.
Until end of August,
there was an airplane
that appeared over the
skies of Auschwitz.
It was flying really low, and
I could see the American flag
on one of the wings.
That gave me hope that
somebody was trying to free us.
And hope in Auschwitz
was in very short supply.
The air raids continued
and increased.
And by November of 1944,
it felt like a full fledged
battlefield-- continuous
air raids, artillery,
all the experiments stopped.
Anyways, the children
developed a daily slogan
that someday soon we will be
free, and we will go home.
Except we had no idea
how that would happen.
In early January,
the Nazis told us,
everybody out of the barracks.
We are taking you
deep into Germany
to protect you
from the fighting.
In my childish mind, I
didn't like the Nazi guards
when they were winning
the war, so I really
didn't want to be near them
when they were losing it,
and we decided to
stay in the barrack.
And I think-- as I
talked a few months ago--
a few years ago to
a survivor-- I said,
why did you go out
on the death marches?
And they came in with their
guns, and pointed at our heads.
Well, no one came
in to our barracks,
so I guess I had
a guardian angel.
Next morning we woke up,
opened the barrack doors.
All the Nazis were gone.
We were on our
own-- about 8,500,
according to the
Auschwitz Museum.
And then the Nazis came
back on January 18, 1945,
to march us to Auschwitz,
and try to eliminate as much
of the evidence as they could.
What I learned that they were
also killing without any rhyme
or reason, because there
was a group of us-- 200
in the kitchen-- and
when we went outside,
the machine guns
were just killing
without any rhyme or reason.
And what I remember
was a barrel of the gun
about three feet from my head.
And I think that when I
woke up, I looked around
and I was surrounded
by dead bodies.
And when I reached
out and touched
one of the girls next
to me, she was ice cold.
And this is when I realized
that I was still alive.
They marched us from
Birkenau Auschwitz II
to Auschwitz I in the
middle of the night.
When we arrived there, the Nazis
were not willing to give up,
and the Allies were right
outside the city limits,
so they couldn't
take us any further.
Heavy fighting was raging
for the next nine days.
My biggest problem in
Auschwitz I was there
was nothing to drink.
And we were very
smart survivors.
There was no snow on the ground.
We would have melted the
snow and boiled the water.
So in sheer despair one day,
I went to the nearby river.
I broke the ice, lowering a
container tied to a string,
and when I looked up,
I saw a little girl
with braided hair, dressed
in beautiful, clean clothes,
and she was carrying
a school bag.
That was my first
realization that there
was a world beyond
the camp where
children looked like
children, and went to school.
A few days later,
it was very quiet.
Eerily quiet.
I thought, well, maybe this
will be the day we will be free.
We didn't know how.
It was late in the afternoon
of January 27, 1945.
A woman ran into
the barrack yelling
at the top of her
voice, "We are free.
We are free.
We are free."
It was a wonderful
event to hear,
but I didn't know
whether or not she knew
what she was talking about.
Because when I looked down
from the second story,
I couldn't see anything.
I said, does she really
know what she is saying?
So we went downstairs.
It was snowing heavily,
and it took me 30 minutes
to get my eyes and vision
adjusted to the falling snow.
Where at a distance I
could see lots of people.
They were all wrapped in
white camouflage raincoats.
They were smiling
from ear to ear.
And the most important
thing, for me,
was that they didn't
look like the Nazis.
So we ran up to them.
They gave us chocolate,
cookie, and hugs.
And this was my first
taste of freedom.
For me to realize that
Miriam and I were alive.
That my little promise to myself
that first night in the latrine
became a reality.
And that was an
unbelievable experience.
I want to say thank you
all for listening to me.
And today's lecture
is 134 this year.
Which means,
basically, the reason
I'm telling you
that I talk a lot.
[LAUGHTER]
And why do I talk so much?
Because I have learned some very
important lessons in my life
that I call them
life lessons, and I
want to share them with you.
Life lesson number one.
Never ever give up on
yourself, or on your dreams.
If you give up,
nothing will happen.
And as I look at many
of your young faces,
I realize I remember
growing up is very hard.
And it's very hard even if
you live in the United States,
and even if you
have loving parents.
And what a thought that is.
That every child
in the world would
be born to loving parents.
Wouldn't that be wonderful?
And even if your loving
parents have enough money
to buy you jeans
with holes in them--
I don't know why
that is so important,
but I know it's more expensive--
and even if they can buy you
all the modern
gadgets, even then,
every single one if you
wonders how on earth
do I fit into this big,
big mixed up world.
Will I be able to accomplish
in life what I set out to do?
And I can tell you that
if you keep hammering away
at your wonderful
minds-- and you
have lots of wonderful minds
working here at Google--
will give you an answer.
I had no idea how to
survive Auschwitz.
And here I am 70 years later,
very happy that I am alive.
Life lesson number two
deals with prejudice.
One of the reasons that
Adolf Hitler and the Nazis
rose to power, it
was a bad economy.
And once Hitler convinced
his fellow Germans
to vote for him-- and he
had only 1/3 of the vote,
but somehow he became
chancellor of Germany.
Instead of taking care
of the economic problems,
he decided it would be a lot
faster to blame it on somebody,
and Jews were always a good
group of people to blame it on.
And many of the Germans
accepted the fact,
because for centuries--
generations--
Jews were always used as
the scapegoats for all
the problems in the world.
And they are used again.
Just yesterday I got on Twitter
a piece of information that
Angela Merkel asked
many Jews in Germany--
as Rosh Hashanah and the high
holy days are approaching--
not to go to the synagogue,
because they might be
firebombed, and they
cannot protect them all.
So in 70 years, I don't
see how much has changed.
And in many countries in
Europe that is a problem.
Prejudice-- I call prejudice
a cancer of the human soul.
It destroys the people
who practice it,
and it destroys
everything in its sight.
But that's what Hitler used.
And prejudice, as we look around
in the world today, is rampant.
Now I will tell
you, I will confess
to the fact that
I am prejudiced,
but not against any race,
religion, or ethnic group.
I basically don't like
the torn-- the jeans
with the holes in them.
[LAUGHTER]
And I don't like the sloppy
appearances of people.
And I know that here at
Googleland, or Reddit,
or wherever we
visited yesterday--
Facebook and tweet-- everybody's
dressing very casually.
Very casually.
I am a much more
formal person, and I
feel comfortable
wearing a jacket,
because I don't want anybody
to see all my bulges.
If I had a gorgeous body, maybe
I would not wear the jacket.
But what I am really concerned
about is for schools.
Children from age six to 18--
and even little 11-year-old
girls-- want to look
sexy, because, of course,
they learn from the movie
stars, and from the movies,
and the media that
that is a way to look.
And they flaunt their little
bodies with low cut blouses.
And they flaunt what they
have, or they wish they had.
I don't know.
So I don't like that.
I think that students
in school should
look like students in
school, and concentrate
on improving their minds.
They have enough time
to look sexy and sloppy.
I will tell you one thing.
When I dress up-- we
used to be younger,
went swimming in
a bathing suit--
I acted a little bit less
formal than I act in my suit.
So the way we dress does have
an effect on the way we behave.
That's my opinion.
So I see when I
talk to teachers--
and see some of the little girls
with shorts that their tush is
sticking out from
it-- I said, is that
appropriate for your dress code?
They said, not exactly,
but it's too much work
to check it all
out and control it.
I don't like guys
with pony tails,
and I'm sure there
are many here.
Body piercings, tattoos,
and any of that.
I don't know why
it's so important
to make holes in your body when
you don't really need them.
I don't know.
Anyway.
Obviously I have none,
even the traditional holes
that women have, I don't have.
I don't like-- and tattoos.
I didn't know that that much ink
in the body make you healthier,
I don't know.
But that is what the style
and the tradition is now--
or the people use it a lot.
So about 16 years
ago, I was invited
to lecture at a
local high school.
And I'm heading
to the auditorium,
and in front of me are
three young 16-year-old boys
with baggy pants.
Now there is a style of
clothing that makes no sense.
If they had to run for their
lives, do you think they could?
They would have to pull
those pants up, or take them
up-- one of the two.
So they were walking
in front of me.
The crotch was the
height of the knee.
They were holding the
pants up with a hand,
and the bottoms were
cleaning the hallway,
as I was walking behind them.
When one of them accidentally
dropped the book, and then
he has the audacity to
bend down and pick it up.
I can tell you I saw places
where the sun never shined.
I was so embarrassed
I had to turn away.
Then I got mad,
because this school
was in my tax district-- was
supported by my tax money.
So I went up to the teacher
who invited me, and told him
what happened.
And I said to him, these
three boys look like bums.
Because people with baggy
pants don't look very sharp,
in my opinion.
And why would anybody
want to look like a bum?
They probably are on
drugs, or drug addicts.
And he told me immediately
that these three young boys
are very good students, and
they have never used any drugs.
I was shocked.
But I realized that even
I have to take the time,
and get to know the
person, and judge
each person on their merits.
So in the last 16 years,
I haven't changed my mind
about liking these
styles of clothing,
but I have made an effort
not to jump to any conclusion
without getting to
know the person.
Life lesson number three.
I forgave the Nazis.
I forgave everybody.
And if anybody would have
asked me 22 years ago today,
if I forgave the Nazis,
I would've told you,
please find a really
good psychiatrist.
I had no intention
of forgiving anybody.
I was angry with the world,
and I hated everybody.
And I can tell you people
have difficulty today
to really believe that.
But I have written a
poem in 1985-- 10 years
before I forgave the Nazis--
and when you see that poem,
it's a child's ABC
from Auschwitz.
A is for Auschwitz, a
place close to hell.
B is for Birkenau, where
brave children were.
C is for children,
standing [INAUDIBLE].
D is for dead people,
bodies everywhere.
E is for experiments--
you get-- it's
a poor me, the poor victim,
all those things that
were done to me.
There was nothing
that I could do.
So when people read
that poem, they
realize that I have
come a long way.
And nothing really happened
to me until my sister died,
and I was asked to a few-- more
than a month after her death,
unrelated to her death, I
received a telephone call
from a professor at
Boston College who
said to me, Eva Kor, I have
heard your presentation
at Boston School of Medicine.
I am doing one of
those conferences,
and I would like you
to come to Boston,
and lecture to some doctors.
And he said, by the way,
when you come to Boston,
it would be really
nice if you could
bring with you a Nazi doctor.
Stunned at the
request, I immediately
blurted out, where
on earth do you think
I can find one of those guys?
They are not advertising
in the Yellow Pages.
in Google either.
So he told me, think about it.
Maybe you'll come up with
some kind of an idea.
And I did.
I remembered that
the last project
that Miriam and I worked
on was a documentary
on the Mengele twins done by
German television, finished
in March of 1992.
And there was a Nazi doctor from
Auschwitz in that documentary,
who was not my doctor, but
he was a friend of Mengele's.
So I immediately contacted
in Frankfurt, Germany,
the television network,
ZDF, and told them
Miriam died, would they please
give me Dr. Munch's telephone
number in the memory of
Miriam, and they did.
We contacted Dr. Munch,
invited him to Boston.
He said, no, I'm not
coming to Boston,
but I'm willing to meet
with you, Eva, at my house.
So August of 1993, I
am heading to Germany
to meet a Nazi doctor.
I was so scared.
What I remembered
about Nazi doctors,
I did not want to
experience again.
But I was curious,
maybe he knew something
about our experiments.
And I was curious, why
was this Nazi doctor
willing to meet with me?
I arrived at his house.
He treated me with the
utmost respect, kindness,
consideration, telling me
he didn't know anything
about our experiments
because Mengele always
said the twins experiments
are top secret.
He gave me a good interview
for my Boston conference.
Then out of the blue-- I never
planned to ask him anything--
I heard myself say, Dr.
Munch, by any chance,
do you know anything about
the operation of the gas
chambers in Auschwitz?
And he immediately blurted
out, this is my problem.
This is the nightmare that
I live with every single day
of my life.
And he went on describing the
operation of the gas chamber.
People would be
told that they're
going to take a shower
after the long journey.
The shower rooms were
cleaned, polished,
and they would even spread
perfume in the rooms.
Once the shower room
was packed with people,
the doors would
close hermetically.
Dr. Munch was stationed outside
looking through a peephole.
And he said that the gas did
not come from the shower heads.
They came-- Zyklon B looks
like pallets of white gravel.
They were packed in canisters.
The canisters were
opened outside the roof,
and dropped through vent-like
openings in the roof.
So they came from the
roof, fell to the floor,
operated like dry ice.
So the gas was actually
rising from the floor.
And as people were
suffocating, often
taking their last
breath of air, they
would try to climb
on other people
to get away from the rising
gas, forming a little mountain
of intermingled bodies.
Dr. Munch knew that
the strongest people
were on the top of the pile.
And when the strongest
people stopped moving,
he knew that everybody
was dead, and he would
sign one death certificate.
Of course, no names,
just the number of people
that were murdered.
I told him immediately
that this was
very important
information-- I have never
heard about it before, never
read it in any book, never seen
it in any documentary--
and that I
was going to Auschwitz in 1995.
I wanted him to go with
me, and sign a document
at the ruins of
the gas chambers,
in the company of
witnesses, so years later,
people could not say
that he didn't sign it.
And he immediately told
me that he would love to.
I did not know it was
going to be that easy.
But I got back to
Terre Haute, Indiana,
and I was very excited
that I will have,
actually, a Nazi
who witnessed it,
testify to the operation
of the gas chamber.
I wanted to thank him.
I didn't know how to
thank a Nazi doctor.
I didn't even know
where does one look
for a gift for a Nazi doctor.
So I went to the
local Hallmark shop,
and went to the section
of thank you cards,
and I started reading card after
card for two and a half hours.
And I was very serious.
Two ladies came up
to me, telling me,
you know, you've been reading
those cards for a long time.
I said, yes.
Are you finding what
you're looking for?
Not really.
Well, what are you looking for?
Tell us, maybe we can help you.
Said, no, thank you.
I left the card shop,
but, of course, I
couldn't give up my idea.
And I went back to my own
life lesson number one.
For the next 10 months, while
I was cooking, cleaning,
doing the laundry, or driving
the car for my real estate
functions, when
my mind wasn't too
busy, I kept asking
myself and brainstorming,
what can I give
this Nazi doctor?
How can I thank him?
Lots of ideas
popped into my head.
None of them seemed appropriate
until 10 months later,
with a simple idea-- how about
a letter of forgiveness from me
to Dr. Munch.
I immediately knew that this
was a meaningful gift for Dr.
Munch, but what I discovered
for myself was life changing.
I discovered that I had
the power to forgive.
No one could give me that power.
No one could take it away.
It was all mine to use
it in any way I wished.
So I began writing my letter.
It took me another four
months, and finally I
liked what I wrote.
But then it occurred
to me that somebody
might to read my letter,
and my spelling in English
is terrible, so I contacted
my former English professor
to correct my spelling.
And she got very enthusiastic.
We met three times.
And the third time we
met, she said, well,
Eva, that's nice that
you forgive Dr. Munch,
but your problem is with
Dr. Mengele, not with Munch.
I tried to debate that.
She said, just do me a favor.
She said, when you
go home tonight,
pretend that you are
talking to Mengele,
and telling him that
you forgive him,
because what I want you to
find out for yourself, how
does it make you feel
to be able to do that?
It sounded like a good idea.
And that day I went home.
I closed the bedroom door.
I looked up as many nasty
words in the dictionary--
now I would use
Google, they didn't
have Google then-- as I could
find, and wrote them down.
I read them out clear and loud.
And then at the end I
said, in spite of all that,
I forgive you.
That felt very interesting.
That I, the little guinea
pig from Auschwitz,
had the power even over Mengele.
And my relationship
with Mengele would end
with my letter of forgiveness.
There was nothing that
he could do to change it.
I wasn't hurting anybody,
so why couldn't I do it?
And if I forgave Mengele--
the worst of them--
I decided to forgive everybody
who has ever hurt me.
And that is the way we
arrived at Auschwitz.
Dr. Munch came with his family.
I took my family.
Dr. Munch signed his document.
I read mine, and signed
it, and gave the copies
that I had there to Dr. Munch.
I immediately felt
that all the pain
I carried around for 50 years
was lifted from my shoulder.
I was no longer a
victim of Auschwitz,
nor was I a prisoner
of my tragic past.
I was free of Auschwitz,
and free of Mengele.
I believe, from my
understanding and research,
that anger is a seed for war.
Happy children do not grow
up to be mass murderers,
but angry children might
like to have revenge.
And Hitler himself
was a very angry man,
and felt like a victim.
And so he-- I call therefore
anger-- is a seed for war.
On the other hand,
people who forgive
are at peace with
themselves and the world.
So I call forgiveness
a seed for peace.
If any of you in this wonderful
group of Google people
is angry, all you will really
need is a piece of paper
and a pen, and start writing
a letter to the person,
or persons, who hurt you.
At the end, you must write
the words, "I forgive you,"
and you must mean them.
And if it not going
to make you, I
believe you will feel
liberated, elated.
I would describe the
experience like Maria
in "The Sound of Music,"
being at the top of the hill,
and fresh air breezing
all around her.
And if it works for
you, I hope you pass it
on to other people who need
it, because I need everybody
to help me sow those
seeds for peace.
Congratulations.
You survived my lecture.
I'm ready for your questions,
and answers, and pictures,
and then you can
Google everybody,
everything you want to.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you for your lecture.
You mentioned having been
raised in an Orthodox household.
Did you maintain a religious
identity and religious practice
through adulthood?
EVA KOR: I am Jewish.
I paid too much price for it
to become any other religion.
I am not a very
religious person today.
And the reason that is-- I know
some people have challenged me,
how can you not be religious?
And I will tell you an
interesting observation
that you-- none of
you-- even if you
plan it-- will know
how you will cope
when your life is on the line.
I arrived in Auschwitz.
The first night, I
didn't eat the bread,
because it was not
kosher, even though we
were in the cattle car for
four days without any food.
When I saw the dead children
in the latrine, at age 10,
I could not figure
out what to do.
I decided that I
was going to live.
And for that it meant that I had
to do-- eat everything-- and do
everything to survive.
That is the way I coped
with life and death.
So I discarded that
little religious girl,
and instead of being a
little religious Jewish girl,
I became a survivor.
I never went back
to the religion,
but that doesn't mean that every
person coped the way I coped.
I have met twins
who survived, who
said they survived
because they were praying.
That was not what
happened to me.
And if anybody
thinks, among you,
that you know how
you will cope when
you're facing life and
death, I'm telling you,
you're very naive.
AUDIENCE: So when you
were in Auschwitz,
like you said before,
death was all around you--
what was so different
about your experience?
Do you think it really was
your strong desire to live?
Was there sort of [INAUDIBLE]?
EVA KOR: How come
that I didn't give up?
That has to do with
my early childhood.
We had two older sisters,
and my mother was expecting,
and my father
desperately wanted a boy.
So when he died,
well, he was worried
about somebody saying the
prayer of the dead-- Kaddish--
for him.
Well, the midwife told my father
that there was a little girl,
but he said, don't despair,
another one is coming.
Of course, his hope was that
this was going to be a boy.
So I arrived as the greatest
disappointment to my father.
And when I was five
and a half years old,
one day he said to me, "Eva."
I said, "Yes, Daddy."
He said, "You
should've been a boy."
I knew nothing
about reproduction.
I thought the storks
brought the babies.
I said that I don't
think it's my fault,
and he got very mad at me.
So from that time on, I
was set up to failure just
about every day.
And I remember he would find
some excuse to punish me.
And I remember
talking to Miriam,
comparing notes about
daddy after the war,
and Miriam said daddy
was a wonderful guy.
He would put me on his lap and
tell me stories about his visit
to Palestine.
I said, Miriam, did we
have the same father?
I saw his lap when he pulled
out his belt to belt me.
These were our two
different experiences.
I learned in those four and a
half years to defy my father,
and outsmart him.
So when I arrived in
Auschwitz, I already
had four and a half
years of experience
of outsmarting authority.
Of course, authority
in Auschwitz
was bigger and more dangerous,
but I was not as scared.
Miriam always looked at me,
what I was doing-- like I really
knew what I was doing--
but I did not let fear rule
and ruin my life.
And that is the way I became
so different from the others.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
And my second
question is, when you
were talking about your process
for forgiving the doctors,
and how you would write a letter
to them and then at the end
write "I forgive you."
And you said the key is
that you have to mean it.
So there are people that I would
like to forgive in my life--
EVA KOR: Do not mail it to them.
AUDIENCE: No, no.
I'm not going to.
EVA KOR: Because I had a bad
experience with a friend who
wrote a guy who molested her.
And then he wrote
back to her, and said,
well, I have to forgive
you too, because I
spent five years in jail.
And that's a toxic relationship.
And I don't think
that you can really
repair it, because they live
with their own venomous life.
I don't know.
However, I think that if you can
forgive-- truly forgive, like I
have forgiven the
Nazis-- you open up
a lot of other experiences
to enter in your life
instead of cluttering your
life with pain and anger.
And that is the
reason that I feel
it's so important for
people to forgive.
I also talked yesterday
and other times to lawyers.
And the judicial system
talks about justice.
Well, what on earth is justice?
When I asked very
well educated people,
they have difficulties
in defining it.
And I don't think that
justice really exists,
but the judicial system is
trying to accomplish that.
At the same time,
if every Nazi would
have been hanged after
World War II, I, the victim,
would have still been an
11-year-old orphan who
was used in experiments and
survived unbelievable things.
So how on earth
would it help me?
If the judicial system
would pay as much attention
in healing the
victims as they pay
in punishing the perpetrators,
the judicial system
would work very well.
Because, in my humble
opinion, every unhealed victim
is a potential perpetrator.
Look at the prisons
are filled with people
who were not born
to be criminals,
but something happened
in their lives,
and they are lashing out at
society and whoever they can.
AUDIENCE: I want to thank
you so much for speaking
to us about your experiences,
and what you've learned.
I'm wondering if you could tell
the story of how you started
to speak to groups
like this, and how
that has evolved over time.
EVA KOR: That is a
very interesting thing.
First of all, I
used to be scared.
I was a member of a Jewish
woman's organization,
and they made me vice
president of one branch.
And I remember getting
ready for those reports,
my stomach was in knots and
I could hardly hear my voice.
But after two,
three years of that,
I became president
of that organization.
And I voiced my opinion clearly.
Now I did not speak about
my experiences until 1978.
I never made a secret out of it.
I never covered my
number, and if people
asked about where did the number
come from, I would tell them.
And I have a cute
little story about that.
So you would understand
how children's minds work.
My daughter, whose name is--
oh, I cannot give out her name.
She doesn't like to be famous.
She lives in San Francisco.
But she was three years old and
she had a little friend, Jill.
And she went for a slumber
party with her friend Jill.
And Mrs. Baker-- Jill's
mother-- fixed breakfast,
my daughter said, Mrs.
Baker, where is your number?
She said, what number?
She said, well, my
mommy has a number.
I thought all
mommies had numbers.
So that is the way children
understand the world.
So Mrs. Baker said
to my daughter,
no, not all mothers
have numbers.
So why does my
mommy have a number?
She says, you better
go home and ask her.
So she came home
skipping and hopping.
She said, mommy, you know Mrs.
Baker doesn't have a number.
I said, I know that.
Well, how come you do?
I said, well, you know those
bad guys-- Nazis-- killed
your grandparents?
They also put a
number on my arm.
Oh.
And she wanted a simple
answer, I gave her the answer,
and she was happy with it.
But children always
feel whatever
happens to them, that
is the way the world is.
So I didn't lecture.
The Holocaust show was shown
in the United States in 1978.
I was contacted by Jewish
organizations in New York
to make sure that our
local affiliate would
carry the docudrama.
I didn't know what
a docudrama was.
And so I contacted
the local NBC station,
and I told them that I was
wondering, in that docudrama,
if they had documentary footage.
And they asked me why.
I said, because I want to
know if I can recognize it.
What do you mean?
You were there?
I said, well, want do
you think this accent is?
And I said, yes.
They said, no, it's based on
the actual documentary footage,
but it's not
documentary footage.
It will look similar.
So because they realized
that I was a survivor,
they asked me to appear
on the nightly news
the first night
that the show aired.
And they got such
a strong response,
they wanted me back
the last night.
And local junior high
school students--
first was a junior high
school student-- contacted me,
and said, would I be willing
to lecture at the school.
I said, sure.
I didn't know exactly
what I was going to say,
and I think I talked
for three hours.
The school was shut down.
And then other schools asked
me, and civic groups asked me,
and after maybe
10 or 15 lectures,
I realized that everybody was
interested in how I survived.
So then I decided to write
down, because the mind that
has an interesting thing.
You start talking
about a topic, and it's
like branches of a tree.
Grow-- other memories
keep running into it.
So you have to focus on
what I needed to say.
And so I designed my lecture.
I wrote it out.
And I write it out, how
I survived Auschwitz.
And I started to add
lessons much, much later.
But an interesting thing.
I was always very cool,
calm, and collected.
I never had any emotion,
and I was very proud of it.
But from 1978 until 1985,
I finished every lecture
with a very strange statement.
I said, I know it
happened to me,
but I always feel
like I'm looking down
at that little girl,
and telling her story.
And nobody said, that's
a strange statement.
Why are you saying it?
They think that survivors
are very fragile.
I am not.
Anyway, in 1985, I was lecturing
at a local university-- Indiana
State University-- and it
was September of 1985--
and I described the
separation from my mother,
and I began sobbing
uncontrollably.
I did not have a
hanky in my pocket,
because I never needed one.
I'm sure I have one now.
And I was wiping my nose, it was
embarrassing, it was terrible.
And every lecture after
that, similar experiences
I had until maybe
50 lectures later,
I realized that something
changed in my relationship
to my story.
And I realized that
never again did
I say, at the end of my lecture,
that I'm standing up here
looking down at that little
girl, and telling her story.
Because that little
girl and me became one.
And I could feel
all of the horrors
that I have experienced
in the camp.
My lectures have
evolved tremendously.
And some people have heard
my lectures 25 years ago,
because I've been
lecturing now 37 years.
And they say they liked it
then, but they like it more now.
So I don't know.
And I don't have any
recorded lectures
from those early times.
AUDIENCE: As time goes
by, just unfortunately,
we will have fewer
opportunities to hear
from people, such as yourself,
who experienced all of this
firsthand.
And documentaries, and letters,
and so on are helpful--
or recordings of
lectures are helpful--
but there's something
to be said for hearing
from someone themselves.
EVA KOR: Well, I decided I
was going to live forever.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: But my
question is what
is the best way in
which we can allow
these stories and these lives
to live on 50 years from now,
100 years from now?
EVA KOR: Well, I have
visited the Shoah Foundation
in Southern California
University with Stephen Smith,
and they are willing to
produce a hologram of my life.
We are trying to raise the
money for it, because it's not
any kind of money that I have.
And I have interacted
with the hologram
they have created of Pinchas.
So I don't know if that
is going to be the answer
to your particular question.
Would you like to say
anything, Kiel, regarding that?
KIEL MAJEWSKI: Hey, everyone.
My name's Kiel.
So I'm the director
of Eva's museum.
But basically I'm
just a guy-- I'm
not Jewish-- I'm just a regular
guy who thought this lady's
story is powerful, and needs to
be preserved and shared widely,
both now and in the future.
And I want to take
your question,
and turn it back on you guys.
Because this is Google,
and if something
can be done that's crazy
and futuristic anywhere
in the world, it's right
here on this campus.
So maybe people don't have
answers or ideas right now,
but let that germinate.
How can we take
this lady's story
and elevate her
platform both now
and for generations to come?
EVA KOR: Boy, that's
a big assignment.
[LAUGHTER]
You thought I was tough.
Look at that.
AUDIENCE: I've
wanted to know-- I've
read in accounts
from other survivors
that Mengele, at times,
gave treats to the children,
or treating them
almost as described
as like a kindly father.
I want to know is that really
true in your experience?
EVA KOR: I have heard from
twins who have received candy
from Mengele.
You have to understand the
relationship between us
and Mengele was one of
the most complicated
human relationships.
We knew, within the first
month, that he probably
was responsible for the
deaths of our families.
Yet he was willing to do-- as
long as he wanted us alive--
he was willing to do
anything to keep us alive.
And in the eyes of
many of the children,
he replaced the father
that they no longer had.
And so therefore, I
was a very angry child
when I arrived in Auschwitz.
And I am sure that my instincts,
and my vibrations, Mengele
got that I didn't want to
have anything to do with him.
So he never gave me any
candy, nor I don't think
that I would have taken it.
I don't know.
Because we were
starving to death.
But I definitely
was not one of those
that Mengele would treat like
his sweet little children.
I was angry.
And I don't really
know how people--
but I know that if
I enter into a room,
I can sense it if this
is a friendly group
or a dangerous group, and
I head out even though
without knowing anything.
So I am sure that
being ever close to me,
he did not get any
good vibrations.
And I was a tough cookie.
Yep.
But I heard about it, and I
believe it definitely happened.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much
for the little team, who kind
of brought us all out here.
It has been an honor for me to
spend an hour in your presence,
and I think I probably speak
on behalf of everyone here.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
EVA KOR: Thank you very much.